okay so plutonium I think plutonium is
quite well known for the fact it's been
used in certain types of nuclear bombs
it's a very interesting element it's
incredibly dense
if you hold a golf ball size shape of
plutonium in your hand it would weigh in
excess of half a kilogram which is one
heavy golf ball and if you were holding
it you would have to be holding it
through several layers of gloves at
least one of which would be lead-lined
and as you held it it would be like
having a really hot cup of tea in your
hand and that's from the major activity
coming out it's just the sheer heat of
the reactivity which you would be
feeling I've not seen any because the
sort of facilities you need to be able
to handle it are way beyond what you
find in a normal University I've heard
some new fascinating stories about it
though such as it's incredibly dense and
a few people at the atomic weapons
agency wanted to cut a little piece off
and it took three of them were the hacks
or several hours and several hacksaw
blades before they finally got a tiny
little chip off so it's incredibly dense
and hard hence the high weight for its
size and perhaps a little-known thing
about lutonium because obviously it has
a pretty bad image in terms of its use
in nuclear weapons is that it's what
helped power the astronauts on the moon
landings in the 60s and 70s